NATO stands with Ukraine
we stood by you after Russia's illegal
annexation of Crimea in 2014
we stand by you today in your heroic
fight against
the Russian Invaders
and in defense of your country
and we will stand by you tomorrow
as you rebuild a work toward a brighter
future for the Ukrainian people
we do not know when this war will end
but we know that Russian aggression is a
toxic pattern that must be stopped
we agreed on the importance of a just
unsustainable peace
and I strongly welcome
president zlenski's peace plan
we must continue to strengthening
Ukraine's Armed Forces
and we must ensure that robust powerful
arrangements are in place
for Ukraine's security
let me be clear
Ukraine's rightful place is in the
euro-atlantic family
Ukraine's rightful place is in NATO
and over time our support will help you
make this possible
today
the president and I discussed a
multi-year support initiative
this will help you transition from
Soviet era equipment and doctrines to
Nato standards and ensure full
interoperability with the alliance
it is a testament to NATO's long-term
commitment Ukraine
NATO stands with you today tomorrow and
for as long as it takes
so president zelinski
thank you again for hosting me here
today I look forward to welcome you to
the NATO Summit in business in July